it's time for our very special
pop quiz
okay one audience member will get to
step into our money booth and grab cash
couch cash
and there's two special tickets in there
a gold ticket uh this is uh if they pick
this one they get a grand prize
what happens if they pick the other well
they pick the silver ticket the entire
audience goes home with a grand prize
all right
all right let's meet our contestant
where is lisette scott
[Applause]
how are you so excited
i'm so excited where are you from i'm
originally from brooklyn but i just
moved to new jersey
to the suburbs
i love it i'm a mom of two so i need a
little more space and they're getting it
and i'm also a small business owner so i
needed space i needed office space for
the babies i just
we had to make the move out of our one
bedroom apartment oh yeah
what's your business i am the owner of
jam enrico a fashion jewelry line
inspired by the caribbean so drew i know
you love the jewels i really do and i
have got to tell you the second you came
down here i was like i love her jewelry
thank you thank you and yeah i got some
hoops for you too look at that where can
we get this um online at my website
www.jamenricojamandrico.com
[Applause]
and celebrate we love small businesses
here and actually the holidays are
coming up and we do a small business
gift guide rather than the items we
focus on the businesses so guess what
please come join us in our small
business guide
[Applause]
all right
but first we're going to ask you three
questions about today's show and for
each question you get right that's 10
seconds in the money booth all right
let's set are you ready i'm ready i'm
ready
what iconic show spoofed billy porter
singing to a flower you were on saturday
night live last night um
[Applause]
okay question number two in what new
york city borough did pete davidson and
kim kardashian recently have dinner and
then the night before that they shared a
private rooftop dinner in staten island
where p is from the king of staten
island a statin island
[Applause]
20 seconds in the booth okay
okay final question for ten more seconds
it is national what day it's national
donut day
[Music]
[Applause]
get your apron on there's a marsupial
pouch in the front of it with cash
you've won 30 seconds total in that
money booth go for it just go animal
okay i'm going to put in the silver and
gold bills right now
we're ready to grab
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
all right we're going to go to a quick
commercial break and count the money
that leset grabbed during the break
[Applause]
[Music]
okay welcome back before the
money as she could in breakthrough money
booth lissette are you ready to find out
how much you won yes i'm so ready all
right well i got to tell you you are our
biggest grabber of losers
[Applause]
there's all different kinds of dollar
bills there we got singles fives
twenties but you grabbed a lot of
hundreds okay
are you ready for your total you have a
lot of space to fill in jersey house
three thousand two hundred and twelve
dollars
anybody grabbed so i thank you for
taking us to
the arc of the story because that is
above what anybody else was able to grab
amazing i'm so excited i'm so excited
well there's other news you also grabbed
the gold ticket
[Applause]
you won a fully assembled wooden swing
set from discovery
[Music]
i have a three-year-old boy and a
three-month-old little girl
and a yard to put that in yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well we have some other news too oh my
god we didn't just grab the golden
ticket you grabbed the silver tickets
[Applause]
you're all getting that
[Applause]
i'm so excited and so happy to be on the
show and i really really appreciate it
and small business gift guide and
everybody thank you for choosing to
spend your time with
us we make this show
[Applause]
[Music]